my name is patrick edenhuber i'm the
product owner of the kyogen clc
microbial genomics module which
which will be
the main module that is used throughout
this session i will go
into more details about which products
we have available for micro microbial
and microbiome data analysis in the
following
let me let me first start by
giving our
standard legal disclaimer
chi pro the
gen products shown here are intended for
molecular biology applications these
products are not intended for the
diagnosis prevention or treatment of
disease
for up-to-date licensing information and
product specific disclaimers see the
respective kai gen kit handbook or user
manual
the handbooks or music user manuals are
available on
www.kyogen.com or can be requested from
kiachen technical services or your local
distributor
so today's session will mark the end
point of the newman microbiome base
presentations
we have seen presentations on sample
disruption nucleic acid isolation and
automation enrichment and amplification
the pcr digital pcr and ngs and today
will
will be solely about data analysis
specifically about the data analysis
that comes out of ngs
sequencing machines
during the microbiome day session of of
the
bioinformatics analysis i have asked you
a question about which
which bioinformatics challenges you
would like to see tackled in today's
session
and
and you have
answered that you would mostly like to
see statistical analysis of metagenomic
data this is also what i'm going to
to to focus on today but i will also try
and see how far i can get into
metagenome
assembly whole genome align and whole
genome alignments
and in the end i will also briefly
scratch the surface of the taxonomic
analysis of 16s its since it's
very similar to what we will also be
doing um
today
let me
briefly reiterate on
um which product we're talking about
this is the uh kaitchen clc genomics
workbench premium package
which includes a number of modules the
main module as i have mentioned
previously is the kaitchen clc micro
genomics module for the analysis of
microbial ngs data or and
metagenomic ngs data
in the bottom of this
of the slide you see also the links to
the products
you can
you can also have it a little simpler if
you want to you could
you could just start by googling clc
genomics workbench premium
and
you see all
i've already done done so
and going to this page lets you actually
request a quote and you can get 14 days
of analysis for free so if you're
interested please go to the page and and
request your your quote
here or or a trial
and
this is including
the
the modules i've been talking about if
you most specifically look for
information on the clc microbial
genomics module
you would use your favorite search
engine and
search for clc microgenomics module
on that page you find a lot of
information what the
module is for
and specifically here i would like to
point you to the
manuals
and how to use it but even more
important to get started are the
resources
and under the resources
i will would really like to highlight
the tutorials because they are really
step-by-step tutorials for beginners if
you're not used to working with clc yet
there are video tutorials
and and
[Music]
sort of describing how
how our algorithms perform we have
benchmarks application notes and white
papers also listed
yes and then it's already time for the
live
demo
so
this is the clc genomics workbench
21.0.4
um
in
if
so this is also what you can see here is
the the standard welcome screen it
already presents you with some
possibilities where you can
choose and select
to for example import data get started
open the welcome center that direct
links to
to different plugins and
information which we think that are
necessary or interesting for you to read
for example also tutorial
data is listed here
but in general this this space will be
will be occupied by
by whenever you open a data element sort
of the visualizations of your data
in the upper left so in the top row you
you find in in the upper left top row
you find the different
buttons which you which you can use to
import export data launch launch tools
which are which you would like to launch
cut copy paste deletes sort of standard
controls below that is the navigation
area where your data elements are stored
in a typical folder structure
and and you would be able to
um yeah to structure it in the way you
you like to
below the navigation area you will find
the toolbox
note also that the toolbox again
reappears in the very top of the screen
as
as one option
this
this under the toolbox pane here or in
the top you will find all the tools that
that are available for you some of the
tools will only become available upon
installing a specific plugin for example
this microbial genomics folder here
that will only appear when you have
installed the microbial genomics module
in order to install modules i would like
to point you to the upper right corner
of the workbench where you can either
select to
to go to your workspace
there's a plugins button a references
button
and some download buttons will will
start by looking into the plugins button
because
you have requested that
you you would be interested in seeing
how whole genome alignments are
performed for this we also have a
specific plugin so you would open this
plugins download plugin
find the whole genome alignment plugin
click on download and install
accept the terms
and
close and restart the workbench
and and then you will see that
there will be a a new folder in the
toolbox that is called whole genome
alignment
so
this is
this is the folder and it comes along
with some tools we'll have a brief look
into those later
let me
let me now present you with the data we
are going to analyze today
we will be looking into a
paper that is called genome sequencing
of sewage detects regionally prevalent
stars cov2 variants
so this is
this is not so much a
human microbiome
analysis as it's a human-associated
microbiome we are looking at
specifically it's um
the this is
about
uh viral enriched reeds or by
reeds that have been enriched for viral
sequences but it's still a metagenomic
sample
and it's a mixture between stool and
everything else that ends up in the in
the sewage
so the
the way to analyze this kind of data is
very similar to how you would analyze
human microbiome data the difference
often is that
in the human microbiome data you would
expect
many human reads depending on how you
did your sequencing so you would try to
remove those um
during the analysis
um we're not going to do this here
because
the
because of the enrichment process most
of the reads are already
or many of the reads are already viral
reads and will only focus on that part
so to find to find the respective data
let's see if there is a bioproject
number in here
and and there is
so we can we would like to download
the the data that is uh associated with
that paper
and we can do so
by by copy pasting this
this bio
bio project number
and then we can use the next button up
here that is called download
here you have several options we'll
choose search for reads in sra
this
will just look for the bio project
because we know it's a bioproject number
it's a it's a little big bit quicker if
we only search that column
um
click enter and then you see a
bunch of lines appears
if we can now
inspect the metadata or select them all
and choose to download reads and
metadata i've already done that because
the download takes some time what you
will then get is a
is a couple of reads files and some
metadata that is associated with those
with those reads
the interesting thing now is that the
reads elements are associated with this
metadata such that we can always
analyze our
our
data in in the context of this metadata
one problem here is that the
that some of the metadata does not
does not come directly with the metadata
that is stored in sra but some metadata
is actually only available as an excel
spreadsheet that that lies
under the um
yeah that is only available from the
channel's homepage
i've also already downloaded that
and stored it into my
into my um
uh
yeah on my machine
well in this in this
spreadsheet i have associated the run
accession numbers with the sample names
that are
coming from
sra
that which is yeah which is basically
this library name here
and the run accession number so so in
this way these two metadata data tables
can be joined we'll use that later
so what what we would
a typical analysis starts out by by
cleaning up the reits in some way
so we would like to trim the reeds
remove adapters and things like that
in order to do that we can
we can
we can use a tool that is called trim
reads you can either navigate to it in
the
very um
very large and comprehensive toolbox or
my
my my favorite way is to actually search
for it because then it will filter the
the large list of tools down to what is
interesting so if i search for trim
reads here then i have only a few
options left and this is the tool we are
looking for trim reads
a
in this case a wizard will open and then
we can select the reads we want to we
can either do so by adding them
individually
or we can right click on the reads
folder and say add folder contents
we'll choose next
keep
keep all as is
we'll just believe that the reasonable
standards um set in the
in the wizard for now
and then the last step lets you either
open uh or select some output options or
it lets you save or open the result
we'll choose save
and
make a new folder with the trim treats
and
click on finished and this is the folder
where where our reads will be stored
into if we now go to the processes
button
tab in the
toolbox pane down here you can actually
see that we now have a an active process
running
so
while this is
of course i have already done some
analysis before because otherwise we
would run out of time here
so i have already trimmed the reads the
output look would look then very similar
you would get all of your reads uh files
again with the trans and the trimmed
trim report which i have chosen to save
here as well
if you open this
report there will be a whole lot of
information about your samples the
number of reads average lengths
how many reads were trimmed and how long
the rates were after trimming
and
and a lot more statistical information
on that
we'll not go into details here
we'll just
we just note for now that these reads
are
are now fit for running a taxonomic
profiling with it which is the whole
metagenome whole metagenomic taxonomic
troll
profiling
which is and that is a read
a tool that that is um
that is available with the microbial
genomics module
let's have a look at what is available
in the microbial genomics module
so
here we can see this is the the folder
structure of the microbial genomics
module we have tools for metagenomics
typing in epidemiology
for
for
isolate analysis mostly
functional analysis and functional
annotations of genomes and
metagenomic
functional profiling
we have drug resistance analysis
and a
folder that lets you download the
necessary databases that are required
for
for building databases that
to analyze metagenomics or
typing data
so for the
the taxonomic profiling tool is of
course to be found under metagenomics
and there we can have two different ways
of analyzing metagenomic data that is
either amplicon based or taxonomic
analysis in this case it's not
amplicon-based but
whole method genome sequencing or
targeted metagenomic sequencing rather
furthermore there is an abundance
analysis folder which we'll look later
into which contains all the tools for
statistical analysis of
metagenomic data
so
so the taxonomic profiling tool is can
be found
here and and once we have selected the
taxonomy profiling tool we can basically
use our trim reads in the same way as
before as follow contents well no it
says select exactly one element
it only lets you analyze one sample at a
time but there is also a solution for
that we can choose to run it in batch
mode that means basically run this tool
one sample at a time and then we try
again add folder contents and then it
will allow you to add all of these
in the next step it shows you the batch
overview all of the individual steps
that will be run
and then you will have to use a database
well now i have already pre-selected a
database that is called clustered
reference viral database
a brief note on that this is a database
that is supplied from the fda
rvdp
and can be found under this
rvdb.dbi.udel.edu
which is the official homepage for the
for the rvdb but we have made it a
little bit more simple for you you can
actually also get the
um
and get the
database
in from within the clc genomics
workbench navigating to the databases
folder
which has the same structure as above
taxonomic analysis and then you can
download a curated microbial reference
database and there you can see that we
offer a range of options
the the kyogen microbial insights
prokaryotic taxonomy database for for
for prokaryotic analysis in this case it
would be viral analysis and you can
choose the clustered reference viral
database
here this is what i did downloaded it as
a taxonomic profiling index and sub
installed it in my navigation area so
again
let us run the taxonomic profiling tool
and why is it we do that
first of all we would like to get an
overview
on
on the um on what is in in those
respective read sets sort of which which
viral species are represented but the
taxonomic profiling tool the small it
also bins your reads it associates a
taxonomy with each individual read
and we can grab those reads later and
analyze a specific subset of reads we
may be interested in
so
um
we can choose to use the we we would
like to produce an abundance table we
would like to produce reads that match
the reference database
we could in principle also choose to
save unclassified reads we're not going
to do that
but we will always would like to get a
report in order to see
what the algorithm has been doing
then we can choose to save in a
specified location and create a
a one sub folder per batch unit that is
per sample it will create all of these
files an abundance table reads matching
the reference database and a report
click next
and then
again we we would make a folder
and choose to save our results in that
folder
now this analysis takes a little bit of
time you can see again it's running
but i will
i will not wait for this to be completed
i would rather
look into the pre-calculated results so
it will look like this once it's done
where you have one
one
folder per
read file
and
now we have
now we have the database messages
stored in that folder an abundance table
that tells me what's in those samples in
a report let's briefly open the report
it's a very simple report it will tell
you how many
how many
different classifications
it came up with on each of the taxonomic
levels so how many different species it
has found it says 43 it found 31 genera
and so on
[Music]
with respect
it also gives some classification of
reads you can see this this sample here
for example only 4 000 viral reads have
been detected
since we used a viral reference database
the 77 000 here were
could not be classified i have
um i have run the taxonomic profiling
tool again on those in a
sort of to to look into what is that and
and many of those reads are actually
actually bacterial reads
but since we are interested in in
detecting sarsko e2
here we
we would we are only interested in the
ones that actually match our viral
reference database and here's only 4 000
which is not too many
but let's have a look into the
um
into into how an abundance table looks
like
an abundance table is basically a table
with
nucleotide references or assembly
references
on the very left that have an associated
taxonomy
and some reads that have been assigned
to it and here you can see that the most
of the reads have been assigned to my
tomato brown rugos fruit virus which is
in accordance with the paper by the way
and made still many reeds have
were associated with the severe acute
respiratory syndrome-related coronavirus
you know you can see it occurs several
times which means there's some there are
several references in our reference
database that have been hit by those
reads so different
different
strains if you want to we can get an
overview over the species by aggregating
the abundance table on a specific level
of the taxonomy
and then we can look into the species
level
and here you can then see the aggregated
number for for the severe acute uh
source of kobe 2.
here 800 reads are not it's not too much
we don't expect that we can
do a lot with
those so we'll have we'll have to look
into a different
into a different sample as well i have
looked previously been looking into this
170 here now we'll do the same trick
again we'll
collect on
on species level
sort the abundance table and then we can
see okay there's something else private
call carrier virus which is the most
abundant one but here we get almost 5000
reads associated with sars kobe 2.
since we
since we selected to store those
database matches here we can just select
that
the respective source code v2 line and
say extract rates from selection
and then it will open a new data element
with exactly those reads
and now we are going into
um
metagenome assembly
um
for for one step because we'll need that
um
we'll need those results later on
so
so
this is this is one way of doing
metagenome assembly where you're really
interested in a specific graph in a
specific species sort of dragging out
those reads from a metagenomic sample
and then looking into which which
species species specifically is um
is
present here
let me
first
save all those reads that are associated
with that species which is the score v2
in this case
so we have these filtered reads
and then we can say
the lenovo assembly
select those
keep all the
keep all the parameters at default we'll
choose this fast route
and then we'll see
oh and this is already done
briefly look into it
and then we can see okay there are a few
a few bigger contexts and some smaller
ones but all in all 14 context
as i said we'll later analyze those a
bit further let's first go back to the
to the
abundance table because
because it's
it is of interest how how to analyze
such a table in in the context of
metadata
so the first thing we need to do
with respect to the abundance table is
that we
that we collect all the the abundance
tables
in into a
single abundance table so the output
from text bro would look like like this
as i said all
one one
one folder per reference
per
read sample so and we have one abundance
table per sample what we need to do is
we would need to run a tool that is
called
merge abundance
table and then
to make it a little bit easier and we
don't want to open each of these folders
individually we can again right click on
the text pro folder and then select add
folder contents recursively so it will
go into each of the subfolders and check
with their fitting data elements
then we have added them all
and we choose to save search and
abundance table
so
now we have an element that is called
merged
if we look into that one it looks a
little bit similar to the one before but
it has many more columns now
one for each of the samples
also what we are what is possible now is
that we can aggregate those samples
based on the metadata
one problem we have is that the metadata
here is not
it's not the main it's not the metadata
we're interested in but what we really
want is the metadata from the inline
supplementary material
so in order to to associate such
external
metadata we have a tool that is called
add metadata to abundance table
which we will just run on this merged
element now you can see because i had
selected it here it's already selected
in the navigation area here click next
in this case i have already browsed and
selected it
we need to make sure that one
one column here is called
name
and that column should correspond to the
names of our samples
and once that is done we can click next
click save
finish
now
now let's see you have briefly seen
something blinking and um and if you are
unsure whether the
the process has been successful well it
does it didn't tell me it was
unsuccessful at least
and i can also look into
by clicking on this small triangle here
looking into the log information and
then it tells me that it associated
metadata for 11 samples of 11 samples so
all of these
samples should have the new metadata
associated now
and it's rather simple to see
that now there there is additional
metadata in here that is
written in non-capital letters and
that's the one that's coming from the
um
from the external
spreadsheet
here it would be interesting to compare
different locations because they have
taken the samples at different sewage
plants
and then we can and then if you select
to to aggregate on on on the location
then you can see the the headers of the
table change and it actually tells me
how how much of each of these was
present
in
the different locales
but there are different ways to
visualize this
we also have a
um
we also have a stack bar chart
visualization in the in the bottom here
oh this is a little bit weird
let me see if i can stop this process
this is probably
something that is doing this yes
um
and
and the stack bar chart will will give
you the species composition at a give at
a different level of the taxonomy which
you can also choose and select for all
of the samples you can for example sort
the samples
according to the metadata and here we
would like to sort them by the location
then we can see how many samples are
associated with oakland berkeley and
marin
but you can also choose to aggregate the
samples based on the metadata in the
same way
sorry the
location
so
furthermore there is a
sunburst editor which lets you explore
the same data in a little bit different
way but again you can choose to
aggregate the sample
based on
for example
location
and it will always show the combined
[Music]
abundance here
but we can also inspect them
individually either for oakland
or berkeley or oakland and berkeley
combined
and you can also increase the level of
resolution here to
to see what is going on further down
well yeah that is interesting but not
um not really a statistical analysis yet
so we have as i said a range of tools
that can be used for the statistical
analysis of such abundance tables
that can be found in metagenomics
abundance analysis and you can choose
for example to create alpha but alpha
diversity beta diversity plots
and terminology analysis create heat
maps
for for your
samples and cluster your samples and
your
uh and your
text respectively
so let's let's have a brief look at the
alpha diversity and i would like to get
the alpha and beta diversities on a
species level so i can either do that
here or later but i'll choose to do that
here aggregate
my features on species say all
and i i select all of the rows and
create an abundance subtable that is now
filtered and
collected on species level
for this one i would like to run the
alpha diversity tool
and i'm now for now only is interested
in the total number as i said you can
also choose to
aggregate here for example on species
lower or any other level
keep the rest we keep as default and
finish while this is running let's also
briefly start the beta diversity which
is much faster
let's choose one of them for now
and we'll
save this here
while alpha diversity is running let's
have a brief look into the beta
diversity
so
oh yes
um
yeah you can see now we had only
we had only three
we have only three samples left that was
because i
selected to aggregate the features on on
aggregate the samples on the location
that was not my intention
but
but you can see that this is also doable
so let's let's for now aggregate on
species level
use again use the sub table
and save it here
we
alpha diversity
next species let's have a few more
points
and
create the beta diversity again
so
close all of the
other ones and then we can for example
look into our samples by um by beta
diversity also here if if they would
cluster you would you would be able to
in inspect it by
by coloring either by categorical
variables or by
by uh by abundance variables
um for now let's have a look at our
location variable and see if if sort of
the locations end up in the same corner
of the the principal com coordinates
components plot
and it does not really seem like it's
it's clustering well also i mean there
are not too many replicas of some of the
examples like
like marin here in berkeley
but there is some difference
so also note that these plots are
available in 2d
and and sometimes you can actually see
signals in those
one other type of analysis while the
alpha diversity is running is the
differential abundance analysis
where you can
choose a an abundance table
and basically compare
groups of samples for example again
we select the metadata table
we would like to analyze it with respect
to whether there are differences in the
related to the
location
of our sample
with the location metadata where is it
[Music]
here this
location you could also correct for um
confounding factors we'll not do that
for now
um there are different ways to run this
analysis either across all of the groups
where you basically lose the group
information but it will tell you is
there something differentially abundant
across those groups we can compare all
the group pairs or we can choose to only
use one control group where we use all
of the
groups that we can
use against one control group let's do
the group pair all group pairs analysis
for now
open it
and then we see okay we get a very big
table where with
for example berkeley versus oakland
marin versus berkeley and marin versus
oakland so all of the group pairs
for all of these
different pairs i get the
the different
taxonomies listed
and
and
and for each of the
for each of the species or higher order
taxonomies if they don't have a
specified species level
i can i can see whether there are
changes when we're between berkeley and
oakland
for example
and then i can also see whether these or
the log twofold changes the full changes
and whether they are significant with p
values and ftr and one for only
corrected p values
furthermore
these group comparisons can be
can be looked at in a
in a venn diagram view by control
clicking on this venn diagram it will
open in a split view
and then you can
select rows from the above
for example by
clicking on on each of the segments
and
note that the numbers here represent the
number of
significantly different
texts
across those groups as defined by the
fdr corrected p value with a significant
level or a significant
significance level of zero zero five
but all of this can be control basically
according to
how much you trust your data
um in this way it lets you identify
differentially abundant species or
otus or differentially abundant
functions across metagenos so these
these
these abundance analysis tools they are
very general and can be used
for all different types of abundance
tables
so now also our alpha diversity process
has finished we can see it it is at a
hundred percent this is the the result
we can either because i know it looks
like that but you can also if you don't
know how it looks you can also
well you can't
you should be able to show results
i'm not sure why this is not possible
here
well if we look at it then we then we
get these alpha diversity curves and we
can see that
oh it actually looks like um some
we capture most of the species so it has
been sequenced
quite deep
which is good
and now we would like to see whether
differences between the groups again for
this there are
we we have an alpha diversity box plot
here which takes um
which takes a different yeah where you
can look at the data at different
rarification levels but only reflection
levels that are present in all of your
samples so
if you only have one available here then
it's
then you either need to increase the
number of points or you need to
you need to remove some of your samples
now now this looks a little bit dull
because for each of the for each of the
samples there is only one point of
course so we the first thing we would
like to do is we would like to group
these samples again by metadata you can
see that under the group by
there is again our favorite
location setting and then we can see
um that there are
that some of the samples that there are
some samples for oakland one for marin
and two for berkeley
and then we can
then we see that they have different num
total number of species detected
whether there are significant
differences
that can be evaluated by
by looking at the p values which
which are displayed above so a crystal
wall is p value across all of the
samples and specific
min whitney
utes p values where you can choose a
reference or where you can choose to
show all of the p values so there may be
a
somewhat significant difference between
berkeley the diversity in berkeley and
the diversity in oakland
so with this i would like to finish the
the
analysis of
abundance tables
and all the statistical analysis of the
abundance tables we feature and get back
to the
metagenomic assembly we have been doing
so remember our context here
we would like to see whether all whether
these contexts are really from from sars
kobe 2.
um
so remember we have we have pulled out
the reads that map to source cov2 with
the taxonomic profiling tool and
assemble them into into context now we
would like to see how they match
for this we have installed the
one way to go about this is to use the
whole genome alignment plugin
which where you can either create dot
plots or create a whole genome alignment
i'll i'll start by creating a whole
genome alignment because i think the
tool has some strengths
for example
it lets you it lets you select a
reference genome
which i choose as the
sarsko v2
wuhan reference
and this reference comes annotated with
cds
and i can choose to copy annotations
from this from the reference to my to my
context now
i i will also keep the rest as is here
and choose to
open
so here i can see oh yeah this seems to
align this seems to align pretty well
and if i now choose to look at the
annotations i can also see that the
annotations have been transferred from
my reference genome indicated by this
little star here
to the to the other genomes this is a
quite a boring whole genome alignment
but let me point out that
the um
the
number of genomes you can put in here
is it can it can be a lot larger and and
then also the whole genome alignments
look a little bit more interesting
with such a whole genome alignment we
can even inspect how good our assembly
has been for example we can
um we can create
average
tight identity plots for this
if we don't select any annotation types
it will be done over the whole genome
and then we can see the alignment
percentage below so we have 92 percent
of the refere of the
reference covered
mn
90
uh so this mn sequence is our reference
right
and
in in those 92 percent we have a 99.94
percent identity
which is which is actually quite good
for a metagenomic
assembly
or with reeds that have been extracted
from a metagenomic sample
if you if you want to do a full
metagenomic assembly without
going through the detour of running
taxonomic profiling and
and dragging out the reads we have a
tool that is called
de novo assemble metagenome
but in this case you would of course
expect that your contexts are not specie
specific but across many species so you
would have to
associate taxonomies to those contexts
after assembly this tool only takes
simply trim treats as input and and
and otherwise you can run it as any
other tool for example let's
do this here
we would choose longer context
and save
now now remember we have just used the
metagenomic context and not um not the
source code too specific ones but this
is just
straightforward
um
so
so after after assembly you would then
have to classify those contexts we have
tools for that i will not go into detail
but there is a plethora of options for
example pinning the pen the
the context with these two tools either
by sequence similarity or by taxonomic
identity using a reference database
and um
yeah and
and then you would
possibly as next step associated with
them with cds
either by aligning it to their
respective references using the whole
genome alignment tools or using the
annotate with blast or diamond tools in
the reference respective blast or
diamond reference database which again
is obtainable in the databases subfolder
last but not least
i would briefly like to mention that if
you have amplicon reads the analysis
steps are very similar to the taxonomic
analysis we have just run only that your
entry point is a bit different
so
when you go to metagenomics there's this
assembly based analysis button
and here we have a tool that is called
otu clustering which you would run
instead of taxonomic profiling
this oto clustering
let me briefly show you
it gives you
gives you also an abundance table on
output and this abundance table is
very similar to the taxonomic abundance
table from taxonomic profiling and it it
can do all the same things in terms of
visualization and downstream analysis
so 16s data and its data is analyzed in
a very similar way
only
that the tool provides some different
options compared to the taxonomic
profiling tool
with this i would like to conclude
today's session and thank you very much
for your attention
i would really be happy if you
if you took
took the leap of faith and tried tried
our software
i i think it's it's very easy to use
it's cross-platform it works both on
linux windows and mac
and and it's easy to install and easy to
use
um other than that we are happy to
to get feature suggestions if you have
them please reach out to us whenever
whenever you feel like it
and
thank you very much for your attention
goodbye